so we'll begin by talking about the
first couple of chapters of Luke where
he tells a distinctive story of the the
birth of Jesus and his early days and
the stories begin with John the Baptist
actually and the announcement of his
birth which is paralleled with an
announcement of the birth of Jesus and
then reactions to those announcements
including a magnificent bit of poetry
put on the lips of Mary the mother of
Jesus the poem known as the Magnificat
and Zechariah the father of John has a
similar balancing poem the Benedictus
and both of them articulates some themes
that are very prominent in in the gospel
as a whole other things David that
strike you is particularly significant
about those well one one picture we've
had of Luke's Gospel and of the book of
Acts is is what one one sense of the
Christian somewhere in the book of Acts
that in them the world is turned upside
down and one of the things I noticed
most powerfully especially in Mary's
song in the Magnificat is that the bitee
are cast from their Thrones and that the
lowly are lifted up and the sense that
that what happens in Jesus Christ as
foretold in this part of the in this
part of Luke's Gospel it's not simply
the individual salvation of each human
being though I think that's important
but a reordering of the social
structures a reordering of history my
puzzle is how does Luke see that
happening well that's my first puzzle
how do you think Luke sees that happen
then I want to think about how we apply
that to our times today but how does the
world get turned upside down that's it
that's a really interesting question the
language seems very political doesn't it
does yeah and he has brought down the
powerful from their throne and he has
lifted up the lowly is still the hungry
with good things and sent the rich empty
away according to the promises that he
made to our ancestors to Abraham and his
descendants forever it's interesting
that Luke concludes on that theme that
there's continuity here huge between
God's actions of old in ancient Israel
and what's going on in his own
environment this continuity but there's
also discontinuity and I think we'll
discover that as we get into it the
continuity I think is highlighted by the
very form of this poem
which seems to be a replication or
inspired by perhaps the poem of Hana
the mother of the prophet Samuel it's
interesting to compare the the
similarities and the differences that
poem that appears in in 1st Samuel
Chapter two has some of the same notions
of reversal and God taking the part of
the poor and the lonely and the
oppressed and I think that's an
important emphasis of Luke all right but
this emphasis of the larger context of a
set of promises going back to Abraham is
something that's distinctive of Luke as
is the theme of God's mercy being shown
from generation to generation which we
get in Luke 150 as part of the the
Magnificat that theme of mercy is very
distinctive of Luke and it ties into his
his insistence that the gospel is really
about compassion forgiveness yeah so
there are two things that that happen in
this or two or three things that happen
in this hymn that first of all the
notion that there's there's a parallel
there's continuity God is working in a
similar fashion but he's doing something
new at the same time yeah one of the
puzzles for me and I've found it
unanswerable so I'm gonna put it to you
insofar as we can make guesses about
Luke's original audience is he writing
to the oppressed to encourage them or is
he writing to the oppressors to call
them to be merciful is this written for
the comfortable over the uncomfortable
or both mmm is it to comfort the
afflicted exactly I kind of have the
sense that he's writing to afflict the
comfortable okay there's a message of
hope in in Luke's Gospel as a whole that
I think they the afflicted can hear but
I think he's really addressing an
audience that probably is a little more
established a little more part of the
greco-roman social order the very fact
that he's writing the the literature
that he does with these literary preface
--is the remind us of a the works of the
ancient historians of harada-san
Herodotus of whose Citadel suggested
he's writing for a literate audience and
the fact that he keeps dwelling on this
issue of wealth and poverty suggests
that he's writing for people who have
some means probably not at the uppermost
layer of Roman society I don't think you
writing for the imperial family or the
roman senate Oriole class but I think
he's writing for well-to-do urban
Christians who are beginning to think
about what their responsibilities are in
the light of God's transforming message
so what passages we'll get to like the
rich man and Lazarus outside the gate is
written more to help the rich man think
about it - well those of us who are
relatively wealthy think about how weird
to deal with the impoverished right of
the impoverished think about how to
protest right the rich so I think that
they came here and this is an
interesting issue that has these these
elements that suggest a notion of
radical revolution and that has been
picked up in some contemporary that is
20th century liberation theology yeah in
situations where that message probably
needs to be heard places like Latin
America for instance which shows
something about the flexibility of the
Bible the Bible can can be applied in
various different circumstances
depending on what those circumstances
are but I think Luke who might have a
bit of poetry here that comes out of a
situation in ancient Israel where
precisely that need for a message of
hope to the oppressed was being
articulated applies it to his early
Christian audience and the emphasis here
is going to be on the responsible use of
of wealth and the way in which this
proclamation of God's option for the
poor has to be heard by and acted upon
by people who are in a position to do so
and that that ties in with the kind of
sense of church community we get in the
book of Acts where they're not the
wealthiest but on the other end
it does include people of some wealth
and it does include questions of
responsibility for the least among them
that's right which i think is also very
important and you've got this Ambika
just to refer to Acts again and I think
as we go through Luke will constantly be
looking at some parallels in acts acts
begins with this image of the early
Christian community sharing their goods
yeah almost a kind of early Christian
community but that small C small C yes
but that that then seems to evaporate as
as long and the community seems to be
more like what we understand it to have
been and by the end of the first century
when this gospel was probably with me
yeah but I think I want to underline
what you also said
one of the gifts of Scripture is that
different people in different social
locations can find in it the promise
that they need and were I and oppressed
and marginalized person I think I'd love
the Magnificat for the opposite reason
that it would bring me hope that those
like you and I like you and me sitting
here in comfort may one day have to be
relativized for the sake of those who
have so much less there is a challenge
here for there is a challenge right and
we'll hear some of that prophetic
challenge in other parts of Luke
particularly the Sermon on the plane
yeah one other dimension of they-they
poem here that i want to call attention
to is the person who says it that is
Mary yeah other oh Jesus what what do
you think about that the role of women
in the third gospel I think there is no
question that at key points especially
at the beginning in the end we have
women as those who bear testimony I
wrote one time in a in an article for
which I get enormous trouble that I
thought in this gospel Mary was the
first Christian preacher because she she
actually preaches the gospel sing as the
gospel maybe she's the first Christian
anthem singer but the anthem is
Proclamation it's gospel and I think
that's an important theme I got in
trouble because it's it people thought I
was making her a question when she was
really a Jew and that it was an
anti-semitic claim I was merely saying I
think that she she presents the gospel I
think that's very important and we'll
see women as those who bear testimony
and received mercy time after time after
time indispensable Luke was very much
interested in women do you think he was
a defender of oh let's say women's
rights to be leaders of Christian
communities oh I think he knew that
women were leaders of Christian
communities and didn't seem to have any
problem with it I think in that sense
whether he was making a case or just
assuming a case I don't know but I think
it's I don't find him saying Oh be quiet
you're just a woman or having the
Apostles say that or Jesus say that so I
think he's I think he's for the kind of
community where leadership is shared
what do you think I think again like
yourself he knows of those Christians I
think he grows out of a kind of Pauline
Christianity and some of the egalitarian
attitudes that we see in Paul's letters
neither male or female erased people
like junior foremost amongst exactly are
there in the background of
Luke I think so too but again I have a
just a little bit of a suspicion that
Luke is moving on toward the kind of
Christianity that we see in other parts
of the New Testament where women have to
be in their place aha
and that they're understood to be
significant parts of the community but
are they really leaders far that's right
there's an ambivalence there yeah it's
somewhat similar I think do they the
kind of ambivalence you see about issues
of wealth and poverty that Luke really
has an important thing to say about the
responsibilities of those in positions
of of wealth and position to do
something about but they at the same
time they can keep the money yeah
so yeah look my great story on this then
I want to get to the rest of birth
narrative was years ago when I was
teaching a course on preaching from Luke
and there was a woman in the class who
was from Ghana and both those things are
important she's a woman and she's from
Ghana and she read this however we might
read this as if she had found her voice
then the Ghanaian Christians had not had
women leaders that they had raised money
to send her to seminary and Mary was her
cry
that her soul magnified the Lord because
like Mary she was able to proclaim the
gospel so I can never hear it without
hearing that at the same time being
problem alright let's let's move to the
the most famous part of Luke's Gospel
except perhaps for the Good Samaritan
and the prodigal son the birth
narratives and in churches where I've
been a pastor every year about two
Sundays before Christmas we have this
retelling of the Christmas story where
the Shepherd's hear the angel and then
the wise men show up and we have the
presenting of the gifts and then they
all stand and take a bow together but
interestingly and Luke - no wise men no
star of just these shepherds and a
manger and a voice that says this is a
sign to you what's the sign what's why
does Luke tell this interesting story I
think an important part of the symbolism
here is the fact that it's shepherds who
are their gifts and acknowledging the
sovereignty of Jesus and this is of a
piece with the the theme that we had
both in the Magnificat and the
Benedictus that God is being faithful
to his promises of old those promises
with promises to Abraham here I think
you evoke David the great shepherd of
ancient Israel and I think Luke knows
and understands that one of the
expectations in first century Judaism
was that there would be a Davidic
Messiah and I think he's suggesting
insinuating that Jesus is the
fulfillment of those hopes and he does
so indirectly here because he has some
issues with that I think and we'll see
them later it's not a dominant way in
Turkey but it's a way of stands nobody
wants to say yes this to is something
that we can affirm about Jesus and also
of course it's that people who are lowly
and marginalized I recognize on this
this game right it's not the major
whether they are wise people law Kings
from least they're the least and the the
least respected among Israel societies
and I think to relative to what we what
we have seen and we'll continue to see
that that while everything is called
into question by Jesus coming not
everything is turned upside down it's
always struck me that instead of simply
wandering off to proclaim the gospel
everywhere they return to their sheep
they return to their sheep glorifying
and praising God and I sometimes think
Luke's vision of what happens in Jesus
Christ is not that tax collectors
necessarily stop collecting taxes or
that teachers stop teaching or that
rulers stop ruling but they do it to the
glory and praise of God and that shifts
the context without necessarily shifting
the job description right there is an
important theme of reversal but how that
repeal that reversal works is may not be
everybody get into sack cloth and ashes
and head out right good thank you